Rob here with a GS news update just one  month after release south park the stick  of truth has dropped in price to forty  dollars from select retailers the new  lower price is available at amazon.com  for xbox 360 playstation 3 and pc while  at gamestop the discounted price only  applies to console versions on steam and  ubisoft's own store the pc version  continues to sell at sixty dollars it is  unclear if the new forty dollar price  point is an official price drop or just  a retailer led promotion but it comes  very quickly after games released last  month gamespot editor kevin van noord  review said a deep role-playing  experience this is not it is fun however  and then I just fought it on a nazi  zombie fetus kind of way overall the  game received a 7 out of 10 for more on  south park the stick of truth and other  gaming news check out gamespot com